[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so the night wears on past midnight.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's now the sixth of Whale Sun and you guys pass through between the Dragon Isles and he turns the boat towards the shipping lines to go to Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Is Merrick on board?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, Merrick's there.
[SPEAKER_03]: I look out to the sea and just tilt my head and use a message.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Would he be the only one to hear it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to do it just to him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's not whisper.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: He uses his magical ability, called message, to send you a message.
[SPEAKER_03]: I go, I say, Merrick.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can talk to him.
[SPEAKER_03]: I say, Merrick, we can't go to that island.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I can't talk to him?
[SPEAKER_00]: You can message back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I can?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, finally.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is all, like, in your mind.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why?
[SPEAKER_03]: King Toli is...
[SPEAKER_03]: He's using the Turtle Dragons.
[SPEAKER_03]: King Toli got a hold of an ancient artifact made by some lich named Azzagon?
[SPEAKER_03]: Acerak.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's using it to control the Turtle Dragons to control his island.
[SPEAKER_03]: If we get anywhere near there, we're as good as dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: If we get near Keintoli's Island.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, that's why the turtle dragons are away.
[SPEAKER_03]: All of them?
[SPEAKER_03]: All.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then he knows a lot about turtle dragons, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do they have eels?
[SPEAKER_02]: Are they amphibious?
[SPEAKER_00]: They're amphibious.
[SPEAKER_00]: They can breathe both water and air.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, they do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's my whole message.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then Bob White was up there, too.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I know of anything, like, in the Dragon Houses?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because no one's been out of the actual land.
[SPEAKER_02]: God knows who, but is it just like...
[SPEAKER_02]: Are they just like big rocks where it's just like, no, you can't really go to that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or is it like their own little things?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, the thing about the islands is that there are reefs all around them that any ship would get wrecked on.
[SPEAKER_00]: The turtle dragons can crawl over that and often do.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's rumored that what they do is they go and lay their eggs in caves.
[SPEAKER_00]: Undersea caves that come up to other areas in the islands, and that's where the females will lay their eggs and keep their clutch.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the males in the seas around them will fight to see who's the strongest they can breed with the females.
[SPEAKER_00]: But this is the time that that normally would be happening.
[SPEAKER_02]: Owen, can you believe this?
[SPEAKER_02]: This is shocking to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I know the water, but... Perhaps the turtle dragons are moving on, Merrick.
[SPEAKER_02]: Doubtful.
[SPEAKER_02]: Extremely doubtful.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is where they...
[SPEAKER_02]: This is hatching season.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is mating season.
[SPEAKER_00]: It'll keep Gion's purse a little heavier, won't it?
[SPEAKER_00]: He won't have to give the yearly bribe to the dragons themselves.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, the dragon wouldn't want to move.
[SPEAKER_02]: They love the yearly bribe.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is strange.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you think Gian would have moved them?
[SPEAKER_02]: Worked out a different treaty that no one else knows about?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I don't even think Gian has enough money to be able to make that happen.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is very strange.
[SPEAKER_00]: I agree.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, we'll keep sailing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't come.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: You want to go over to Gouge?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bard has been talking to me in my head.
[SPEAKER_02]: As pleasant as you might think that is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Better you than me.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know how I said we want to go to the island?
[SPEAKER_02]: Cane Tolis?
[SPEAKER_02]: We're not doing that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Apparently
[SPEAKER_02]: Can Toli, do you pay him off?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or he uses the...
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: The dragons are protecting Toli's island.
[SPEAKER_02]: All of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we go, we're toast.
[SPEAKER_02]: If we go near that island, we are done.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it appears if he's on the move, and he's got something, the dragon's protecting his island, something very, very strange is going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because he wouldn't normally be leaving there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because he's completely protected there?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or he's having something protected there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you think he has them underwater protecting him where he's going?
[SPEAKER_01]: Possibly.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he must be paying them an exorbitant amount or have some type of control over them?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the latter, I believe.
[SPEAKER_02]: Threatening the bard's book of some artifact.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know what the artifact do.
[SPEAKER_00]: It controlled dragons.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it controlled dragons.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess we definitely don't want to fuck with him in any way, form, or manner.
[SPEAKER_02]: I say we continue on with our quest, but this is extremely eerie news.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, something that, something that, did you, I heard something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Try not to pay attention.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, we definitely do not want to make any waves in that aspect, but that's beyond important news.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not sure who that should be shared with either.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, even amongst whoever we're reporting to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's not share that without anyone else knowing what we're doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: That goes for me with you as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Folsom?
[SPEAKER_02]: Aye.
[SPEAKER_02]: Continue what you're doing, but I need to know more about this artifact.
[SPEAKER_03]: Am I next to Owen still?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, obviously he wasn't going to go up and say that to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to go up and say hey?
[SPEAKER_00]: I call Folsom over.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Folsom, good intel.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're doing great, but we need to know more about this artifact.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just kind of go, Fuck you!
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't get any of my red-eye, and I walk away from them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, what was the name of that Agath?
[SPEAKER_02]: Agath?
[SPEAKER_02]: Acerak.
[SPEAKER_02]: Said he was a necromancer?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or a, uh... A lich.
[SPEAKER_02]: A lich.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I go over and take a pull of my own?
[SPEAKER_01]: Go up by Owen.
[SPEAKER_02]: I need to know more about this lich and where he comes from, what that means.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is Acerak a well-known thing?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you have history?
[SPEAKER_03]: I have College of Lore expertise in Arcana performance.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have history as proficiency?
[SPEAKER_03]: I do, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll the dice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fourteen plus four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eighteen?
[SPEAKER_00]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Acerak was actually a lich, supposedly that was in the region of Salimor.
[SPEAKER_00]: And lived 600 years ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: And in some way he was involved in some kind of war between the House of Gratzel.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't know much about this, but one of the Gratzelian kings destroyed him.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't know if he was destroyed, but he defeated someone that Aserach was supporting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't know much about Keoland history.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I mean, you have heard of this.
[SPEAKER_03]: What the hell is going on?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I got this on vinyl.
[SPEAKER_03]: Um... My voice just sounded funny.
[SPEAKER_03]: It was a different tone of voice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Informative voice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you've been gone for a very, very long time.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe the artifact is from then, or made now?
[SPEAKER_03]: For the... For, uh...
[SPEAKER_03]: For Cain, Toli?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: If anything, the artifact...
[SPEAKER_02]: If it was crafted now, that would mean the lich is still alive.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, and it also makes sense for it to be... You don't recall anything about artifacts being used like this before?
[SPEAKER_02]: Should I make a...?
[SPEAKER_02]: Any rumors of this?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do an end check.
[SPEAKER_03]: But I just do history, or just intelligence?
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, history.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a one plus four.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, if you remember correctly, Azrek was, you know, does what liches do, which is raise the dead and do stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, there is a connection that you remember.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Sons of Olan
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously take their name from this guy named Lord Olan that was alive during that period of time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lord Olan was supposedly a vampire that Asarak created.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is all fantasy.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, this is just, of course, stories to scare adventurers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is your hair crawling on your neck?
[SPEAKER_01]: How long has Ty been asleep?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well... Let me see, what time did you get up to sleep?
[SPEAKER_03]: Far after me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I was like, uh, it was, oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got up at like 10 or something, I mean 6 in the morning.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think I went to... You guys got four hours sleep and I was working on a full A.
[SPEAKER_03]: Has there ever, ever been records of the Turtle sleeping Turtle Island ever?
[SPEAKER_00]: You're up now or not?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: They've been here before the principalities.
[SPEAKER_00]: You went back down?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, they've been here thousands of years.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I went up and saw the thing and I went back down.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was like, oh yeah, great, I'd had like two hours and then went back down.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna go down and wake him up.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm still talking to Merrick, and I told him that the artifact, I'm assuming, is my best guess for it to be newer for the fact that if this were made now, I sense why the turtles are gone, and it shows no record of the turtles ever being used.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just because we didn't get caught this time doesn't mean make another run like this, though.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're going to continue on with this quest that Owen has us on towards Redshore.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like I said, I need you to be his right hand man.
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_03]: How close are we to Redshore?
[SPEAKER_02]: We're in the Dragon Isles right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: No one's been here in over 150 years.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, how close are we to Red Shore?
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll make it by the evening of the 6, Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're close.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe another 10 hours.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, Owen, I'm gonna get to work on this boat, clean this boat up.
[SPEAKER_02]: No one's ever gonna believe us, cousin.
[SPEAKER_02]: Glad I could share this with you.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was quite an experience.
[SPEAKER_02]: Once we get us out of here,
[SPEAKER_02]: Out of the aisles here, do you mind taking the helm for a little bit?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to get some more rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Certainly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sweet.
[SPEAKER_01]: And stay alone.
[SPEAKER_03]: Great.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Put it into the wind.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's get it there.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he continues the journey.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys do another 12 hours and head towards the next stage.